la montagne tu les imprudents xii mort
hier aux enfants blessés aujourd'hui
dans les alpes bernard hinault le tour
dans la poche
l'indochine de ma genève le sort des
réfugiés en question voilà monsieur
bonsoir alerte en montagne 35 morts dans
les alpes
depuis le 1er juillet 8 pour la seule
journée d'hier dans l'accident de
chamonix et ce n'est pas fini
une patrouille de 11 coûte blessé près
de briançon dans le glacier dumontier
aujourd'hui bien sûr on sait que
l'alpinisme est un sport dangereux mais
ce dont on est effaré souvent c'est des
conditions dans lesquelles certains
vacanciers s'aventurent en montagne
surtout en cette période de l'année qui
connaît une affluence record par exemple
dimanche sur les pentes du mont blanc
c'était pratiquement l'embouteillage il
y avait près de 300 alpinistes
c'est vrai on a compté jusqu'à 300
personnes en un seul jour sur certains
itinéraires du massif du mont-blanc en
dix ans de la vallée de chamonix qu'elle
était devenue un immense stade de jeu le
regretté guide lionel terray était
encore en dessous de la vérité
d'aujourd'hui c'est maintenant une sorte
de haut lieu touristique où l'on vient
voir le mont blanc de près comme on
vient à paris voir la tour eiffel c'est
la ruée estivale et chacun croit parce
qu'il fait beau parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de monde sur les pentes pouvoir aussi
s'offrir le plaisir d'une ascension et
en famille pourquoi pas la montagne sur
équipée de multiple téléphérique
surveillé par les hélicoptères de la
gendarmerie ponctuée de refuge n'inspire
plus de crainte aux débutants au mieux
prend-il quelques précautions
vestimentaire s'offrant même des
équipements sophistiqués et coûteux dont
cependant l'utilité complètent leur
échappe
pourtant l'office du tourisme diffuse
sans cesse des avertissements les guides
ne refuse pas les conseils les services
météo affiche régulièrement les
bulletins prévisions là les cours
d'initiation à la montagne fonctionne
tout est prévu mais on ne peut rien
contre l'inconscience
avec mes moyens je suis des cours de mes
moyens je fais pas des courses au dessus
de mes moyens
ça sert à rien j'y vois une blague c'est
tout si vous faisions qui arrive de des
grandes villes avec un matériel
sophistiqué qui se disent on va faire
une course très difficile sans avoir
beaucoup d'entraînement à laurent
combien basket basket un t-shirt appelé
mauvais temps ça se rend compte en quoi
ça 50 comme quoi la règle et les gens
sont mal informés
quelles sont les précautions
élémentaires qu'il faut prendre
on veut les précautions élémentaires
d'avancer d'être techniquement prêt
c'est-à-dire de connaître la montagne
d'avoir une série de réflexes donc de
pouvoir intervenir à tous les moments
d'avoir des réflexes qui soit à la fois
technique c'est à dire de pouvoir
s'assurer de pouvoir se protéger aussi
des reflex haut niveau à climatologie de
la météorologie
se renseigner toujours avant de partir
en course être très bien équipé
simplement il peut faire très chaud il
faut toujours garder duvet sur soi
efforts toujours la nourriture sur soi
il faut aussi prévenir les gens que l'on
part en course donc et puis surtout il
faut toujours pratiqué la montagne à son
niveau c'est à dire que la montagne ne
permet pas de la dépasser en fait il a
gagné le tour de france il bien sûr
c'est bernard hinault qui en remportant
aujourd'hui l'étape contre la montre de
dijon s'est assuré pour la deuxième fois
consécutive la victoire du tout en effet
à moins d'un accident les trois
dernières étapes jusqu'à paris ne
devrait être qu'une simple formalité
touchons du bois tout neuf
depuis que zoetemelk lui avait repris 50
secondes dans l'ascension de l'alpe
d'huez lundi dernier on le savait
bernard hinault ne vivait plus que dans
la tente de la cause contre la montre
individuel d'aujourd'hui sur un circuit
de 50 km autour de dijon
mais le rendez vous n'a pas eu la
couleur conduit prévoyait en effet on
voyait un bernard hinault éclatant
impérial on a trouvé un champion qui a
gagné autant par son courage et sa
volonté de vaincre que par son coup de
[ __ ]
certes bernard hinault l'a emporté en
reprenant une 0,8 à s'auto m mais ce
dernier victime d'une crevaison qui lui
a fait perdre une bonne quinzaine de
secondes a été remarquable tout au long
de la course
j'ai besoin comme l a prouvé aujourd'hui
qu'il était bien un beau dauphin dans ce
tour de france
quant à bernard hinault est bien le
champion a su aujourd'hui montré qu'ils
savaient se surpasser même quand il
était victime d'une petite défaillance
au micro de robert chapatte
il s'interrogeait sur sa popularité
est ce que par rapport à l'an dernier
vous avez senti au cours de ce tour de
france que le public est maintenant tout
à fait avec vous il y avait encore
quelques réserves l'année dernière
quelques réticences on oubliait pas tout
de suite mais revient paix venait
effectivement plus ça va aller je pense
que plus le public va être pour moi
parce que bon bah bernard c'est
malheureux il n'est plus là vraiment on
n'est plus là non plus et je pense que
le public est toujours à la recherche
d'un nouveau coureur et pour l'instant
c'est moi donc j'espère qu'il y en aura
d'autres
une ombre tout de même à cette victoire
de bernard hinault un de ses coéquipiers
gilbert chômage qui avait subi un
contrôle médical positif dans l'étape de
morzine a été rétrogradé à la dernière
place du classement général
il a également une amende de 1000 francs
suisses la conférence internationale sur
les réfugiés du cambodge et du vietnam
s'ouvre demain à genève
la france par l'intermédiaire de son
ministre des affaires étrangères
monsieur françois poncet doit présenter
un plan humanitaire pour venir en aide à
ces milliers d'hommes et de femmes et
d'enfants à la dérive malheureusement on
risque de voir le débat se transformer
en affrontement politique en effet les
vietnamiens ne veulent entendre parler
que de l'aspect strictement concret et
humanitaire du problème alors que les
chinois entendent bien mettre en
accusation le vietnam et la guerre qui
l'a mené au cambodge par exemple action
qui selon les chinois est l'une des
origines de cet afflux de réfugiés
drame dans cette affaire c'est que
pendant ce temps là des milliers de
personnes continuent de s'enfuir avec
tous les risques que cela comporte
on a souvent parlé de ces fameux
pêcheurs qui au large de la thaïlande se
transforme en pirate pour rançonner et
parfois violées c'est malheureux et
malheureuse sujet tive et bien nous
envoyés spéciaux jacquat bouchard et
patrice du tertre eux les ont vus ces
pirates ils vous présentent leurs
témoignages
tel un bateau ivre furieusement ballotté
l'île de lumière si à la mer de chine à
la recherche de vietnamiens en détresse
le commandant établi le contact avec une
plate forme pétrolière hollandaise situé
au large de la côte de malaisie l'aide
il n'est de nuit leur huile 10,6 french
hospital ships île de lumière
colling and will do you read me heureux
d'abord réticent le radio de la
plateforme fini par admettre que le
secteur grouille d'embarcations chargées
de vietnamiens 10 heures plus tard le
navire français croise le canadian tide
un bâtiment ravitailleur de station
pétrolière
il vient de sauver in extremis 264
vietnamiens dont une centaine d'enfants
après sept jours de mer leur chaloupe
notter en panne était déjà submergés par
les vagues
lorsque le canadian tide est arrivé le
commandant du bateau ravitailleur a
d'abord visité décrivant quelques
cercles autour des naufragés mais deux
vietnamiens s'étant noyés sous ses yeux
il a fini par embarquer tout le monde il
s'agit maintenant de transférer les 264
sur l'île de lumière une forte houle
empêche l'opération bord à bord
il faut organiser une navette les
premiers témoignages recueillis sont
accablants pour les pêcheurs thaïlandais
qui rôde dans les parages à l'affût ce
jeune homme véhément indignés pointe un
doigt accusateur
regardez ces bateaux de pêche leurs
occupants nous ont attaqué quatre
français thuir ils ont violé les femmes
l'opinion internationale doit demander
des comptes au gouvernement thaïlandais
pour qu'il arrête ces actes de barbarie
exemple de la férocité de ces
détrousseurs des mères un homme âgé n'a
pas pu sauver ses lunettes il est lui en
prit ni même son dentier ils lui ont
arraché pendant les deux heures que
durera le transbordement sur l'île de
lumière la flottille de chalutiers
thaïlandais se tiendra à une faible
distance comme s'il y avait encore
quelque chose à voler à ces malheureux
vietnamiens les 264 n'ont plus rien leur
maigre ballot leurs derniers effets
personnels ont coulé avec leur
embarcation
les pirates thaïlandais savent que
d'autres proies se présenteront dans les
jours qui viennent
ils se tiennent donc au point de passage
des bateaux vietnamiens avec un armement
composé de hache de couteaux et plus
rarement d'armé à feu en haute mer
l'impunité est pratiquement assurée
est-ce que vous avez rencontré d'autres
bateaux vietnamiens de réfugiés
racing et s
on va répondu à votre millions
en mer de chine
on ne répond plus aux signaux des
vietnamiens la plupart des commandants
de bâton d'ailleurs des instructions
très strictes de leurs armateurs
interdiction de recueillir des réfugiés
aux besoins s'écarter de la route suivie
par les vietnamiens
redit viser à tout prix des mauvaises
rencontres avec ces clochards du grand
large en mer porté assistance à personne
en danger et est un devoir
aujourd'hui dans la mer de chine c'est
devenu un délit le premier sujet abordé
par la nouvelle assemblée européenne de
strasbourg devait être justement l'aide
aux réfugiés vietnamiens mais c'est un
peu triste les querelles de procédure
qui ont continué toute la journée ont
retardé le débat qui vient seulement de
commencer ce soir au centre de la
discussion
la décision qu'a prise la commission de
bruxelles de suspendre l'aide de la
communauté au vietnam sans que les chefs
de gouvernement des neuf se soit réuni
la vie sur ce problème de monsieur jean
denis le communiste et de monsieur edgar
faure ne pourrions pas admettre que
l'utilisation de l'aide alimentaire
on en arrive à constituer une arme
politique
l'aide alimentaire doit être poursuivi
indépendamment des événements pas chez
eux indépendamment de reproches que l'on
peut faire à des autorités en place et
nous ne pouvons pas admettre nous
pouvons pas admettre que la commission
d'autres autorités européennes décide de
stopper l'aide qui avait été convenu un
certain moment au bénéfice de la
république du vietnam
simplement parce que l'on aurait besoin
à des crédits affectables à cette aide
pour des opérations immédiate au
bénéfice des réfugiés où l'on
distinguait l'humanitaire du politique
nous n'entrons pas dans les discussions
politiques nous faisons face à une
situation humanitaire une situation qui
insurge la conscience et de la première
notion notre seconde notion est de
proposer quelque chose de concret et
d'efficace pour cela nous avons prévu
des dispositions financières
une hausse que nous demandons d'ailleurs
en propre terme dans notre résolution
c'est que l'aide humanitaire à tous les
pays nous ne pouvons pas mais fasse
l'objet d'un contrôle approprié de sa
chemise
et ses obsèques à tribune de strasbourg
toujours cet après midi monsieur jacques
chirac lui s'est déclaré choqué par la
décision de la commission de bruxelles
de suspendre l'aide communautaire pour
le vietnam cette décision a dit l'ancien
premier ministre n'était pas de la
compétence de la commission mais des
gouvernements des chefs de gouvernement
des neuf en se prononçant pour
l'imprescriptibilité des crimes contre
l'humanité monsieur jean françois poncet
le ministre des affaires étrangères
français vient de confirmer en quelque
sorte
l'inculpation prononcée le 13 mars
dernier contre monsieur jean leguay vous
en souvenez le représentant du
gouvernement de vichy à paris durant la
guerre monsieur jean leguay est l'objet
de plaintes des familles de survivants
de la grande rafle du vélodrome d'hiver
en 1942 et qui l'accusé de crimes contre
l'humanité alors pas le faire
expliquez-nous cette affaire n'est pas
facile jean leguay a été inculpé le 13
mars dernier par madame le juge anthony
de la cour de paris pour sa
participation l'a décidé à la décision
d'organiser entre autres la rafle du vel
d'hiv en fait pour l'organisation
d'envoi en allemagne de juifs entre 1942
et 44 et le juge s'appuyait donc sur une
loi de 1964 votés par le parlement
français
définissant comme imprescriptibles les
lois qu'on des crimes contre l'humanité
alors la défense de jean leguay
s'appuyer sur trois raisons premièrement
même si les faits sont trouvés il ne
s'agit pas de crimes contre l'humanité
et de crimes de droit commun deuxième
raison les crimes de droit commun sont
prescrits en france au bout de dix ans
et troisièmement la loi de 64 dont
j'aime parler a été à voter après le
délai de dix ans donc trop tard pour
s'appliquer aux faits reprochés à jean
leguay donc pas de rétroactivité des
lois leur prochaine attisé on peut dire
ceci la france a adhéré à des traités
les textes internationaux pratiqué à
convention européenne qui s'appuyait sur
le jugement du tribunal de nuremberg
définissant l'imprescriptibilité des
crimes contre l'humanité mais le droit
français a établi lui des définitions de
la prescription donc il pouvait y avoir
une contradiction c'est le quai d'orsay
signataires et interprète des textes
internationaux qui doit dire s'il ya
contradiction ou pas là il vient de dire
pas de prescription la convention
européenne s'applique depuis la date des
faits donc sur ce plan
l'inculpation prononcée par le juge jean
dany tient à l'encontre de monsieur jean
leguay le symbole du régime somoza est
tombée aujourd'hui le bunker souterrain
d'où le général avait dirigé la
résistance a été envahie par les troupes
sandiniste qui occupe désormais la
capitale managua
la situation ne s'est pas totalement
clarifiée pour autant car des éléments
de la garde nationale continue de se
battre alors que le président de
l'assemblée nationale qui avait succédé
au général sur mozac depuis 48 heures a
lui aussi à son tour pris le chemin de
l'exil 36 courcoult y aura été un
président éphémère les américains l'ont
finalement convaincu de prendre le
premier avion pour le guatemala
ils ont dû d'ailleurs fortement assister
et dans les rues de managua on a vu
arriver les troupes sandiniste
victorieuse les habitants de la capitale
les ont regardés venir incrédule ou
plutôt prudents ils n'ont pas laissé
éclater leur joie dans un premier temps
car la garde nationale toujours
présentes n'a pas déposé les armes
pas encore on ne secoue pas en quelques
minutes quarante années de dictature la
garde nationale avait pour objectif la
défense de somoza somoza partie lagarde
se battent encore
ce jeune homme mort était un garde
nationale il était du mauvais côté
il est mort quelques jours avant la fin
des combats les sandinistes arrivé à
managua ont dit qu'ils ne seraient pas
tendre avec la garde nationale qui sera
dissoute le gouvernement provisoire lui
aussi est arrivé à managua sa tâche va
être lourde
dans un pays aux travaux aux trois
quarts détruit par la guerre civile le
président carter vient de nommer le
premier membres de son nouveau
gouvernement
hamilton jordan un géorgien comme lui de
34 ans qui depuis le début de la
carrière politique de jimmy carter ne
l'a pas quittée c'est lui qui l'a
accompagné dans son ascension jusqu'à la
présidence des états unis
il prend aujourd'hui le poste de
secrétaire général de la maison blanche
c'est à dire qu'il aura la haute main
pour faire exécuter toutes les décisions
présidentielles à noter en marge que
quatre jours après l annonce du plan
énergétique américain par jimmy carter
pour la première fois aujourd'hui
le dollar s'est légèrement repris sur
les marchés des changes internationaux
et puis ce soir on apprend qu'une
deuxième personne a été nommé dans le
nouveau gouvernement de monsieur
quartier il s'agit d'une femme madame
patricia rice qui a été nommé secrétaire
d'état à la santé
et puis une autre femme à l'honneur
cette fois ci au portugal madame maria
de lurdes a été chargé de former le
nouveau gouvernement par le président de
la république du portugal
papeete capitale de la polynésie
française dernière étape du voyage du
président de la république dans les
territoires du pacifique un accueil
chaleureux et un premier discours de
monsieur giscard d'estaing déclarant je
suis venu donner un nouvel élan au
contrat passé avec la polynésie sur
place notre envoyé spécial patrick
poivre d'arvor tahiti l'autre bout du
monde 12 heures de décalage horaire avec
paris pour valéry giscard d'estaing
changement de climat radical après la
fraîche nommé à la chaleureuse tahiti
accueil hasardent pas le moins du monde
alanguie du rythme des chants et danses
une foule nombreuse à l'aéroport malgré
elle
nocturne bref la chaleur des îles pour
le prince qui a rendu les océans le
surnom qu'on donnait les tahitiens au
président cet enthousiasme le chef de
l'état l'avait vécue aux réductions
quelques heures plus tôt dans l'archipel
de wallis et futuna de petits îlots posé
au milieu du pacifique
si loin de la france d'ailleurs la
première fois qu'un fait de la
république rendait visite à ses
lointains ce sujet jeudi sujet à dessein
car figurez vous qu'il y ait ici trois
rois un pur ou alice 2 pour futurs na
qui ne s'entendent guère ailleurs des
rois en cravate mais sans chaussures des
rois passionné par la république
française légitimiste jusqu'au bout des
ongles légitimiste et traditionnelle ils
ont offert au président la sphère et
monique vous allez voir la cérémonie du
kava
si vous voulez une recette de cuisine
vous promet des racines de cette
aphrodisiaques vous les piles et selon
un chiffre compliqué en palabrant
beaucoup vous crachez parfois un peu
dans le plat vous l'été un peu d'eau
vous et saurez vous servez à vos invités
apparemment cela plus au chef de l'état
qui a remercié dans la langue du pays
la sécurité sociale le ministre de la
santé monsieur barreau a terminé ses
consultations avec les syndicats sans
que l'on est encore aucune certitude on
peut déjà faire quelques hypothèses à
propos des décisions qui seront prises
pour combler un déficit qui s'étalait
avoisinera les 3 milliards de francs on
parle par exemple d'une cotisation
exceptionnelle une double cotisation
mensuelle d'ici à la fin de l'année
les premières décisions seront connus
normalement mercredi prochain 25 juillet
à l'issue du conseil des ministres
pas de modification des taux d'intérêt
des caisses d'epargne dans l'immédiat
indiqué aujourd'hui son président ici
d'une rencontre avec le premier ministre
monsieur bart toutefois l'évolution de
l'inflation pourrait peut-être amené le
gouvernement à changer d'avis grève de
24 heures aujourd'hui décrétée par le
syndicat des dockers cgt syndicat unique
dans cette profession cet arrêt de
travail s'ajoute à de nombreux autres
depuis le début de ce conflit a presque
deux ans pourtant le ministère des
transports a annoncé ce matin une
augmentation des indemnités de garantie
des dockers qui était l'une des
principales revendications
mais le différend n'est pas résolu pour
autant qu'à dans les ports très modernes
comme celui de fos sur mer où le trafic
est paralysé depuis près de deux mois
patrons et syndicats s'opposent aussi
sur les méthodes de travail
une enquête d'alain doubiste les dockers
ont refusé la mensualisation aussi
chaque matin ils vont à l'embout rhj et
sont payés à la journée par des
entreprises de manutention appelé aussi
à cogner il travaille 6h40 par jour le
revenu mensuel varie entre 5000 et 7000
francs pour devenir dockers
professionnel il faut répondre à un
certain nombre de critères d'âgés de
santé mais surtout priorité donnée aux
fils ou aux jambes
les dockers professionnelle la loi du 6
septembre 1947 qui régit la profession
précise que les dockers professionnels
ont un monopole dans beauf absolu c'est
à dire qu'il est interdit d'employer un
dockers occasionnels
tant que les professionnels ne sont pas
tous embauchés
de plus les dockers professionnelle et
au sol touche l'indemnité de garantie
lorsqu'ils ne trouvent pas de travail
la demande de relèvement de cette
indemnité de garanties elles se
montaient à 84,81 était la principale
source d'un conflit perturbant
l'activité du port de marseille mais
surtout bloquant complètement le port de
fos car si un conflit est difficilement
supportable dans un port traditionnelle
dans le port ultramoderne de fos il
devient suicidaire dans un port vraiment
industriels comme fausse tout est réglé
de façon tel mouvement les bateaux
mouvement des conteneurs à travers toute
l'europe mouvement d'être un mouvement d
de nos propres marchandises façon telle
que à partir d'un certain degré trouble
la machine s'arrête tout simplement
comme une sidérurgie s'arrête si vous
cessez de la faire fonctionner de façon
systémique fawcett import gigantesque il
reçoit des navires porte containers dont
les mouvements sont programmés six mois
voire un an à l'avance les conditions de
travail sont donc très particulière
force nous at on dit et rentable à
condition d'être ouverts 24 heures sur
24 mais les dockers ont plus de leurs
revendications nationales de salaire
concrétiser par des grève intermittente
font refuser le travail de nuit ou de
dimanche des heures supplémentaires face
à ces conditions d'exploitation des
acconiers ont préféré arrêter langue
gauche le port de fos est fermé depuis
le 11 mai pour certains industriels
c'est l'asphyxient la catastrophe
d'une part nous allons devoir arrêter
nos fabrications et être contraint
vraisemblablement de mettre le personnel
en chômage technique
et deuxièmement les clients que nous ne
pourrons pas servir ne peuvent pas
attendre dans la culture et risquent par
conséquent de disparaître définitivement
de notre clientèle je considère que les
dockers sont une profession qui jouit de
certains privilèges et qui jouit d'un
monopole et je trouve absolument anormal
comme qu en échange de ces monopoles les
dockers ne considère pas qu'ils ont des
devoirs et qu'ils profitent de ce
monopole pour détériorer ainsi toute une
activité économique et du monde maritime
et de tout le commerce extérieur
français toutes les professions du port
armateurs a cogné consignataires
transitaires se liguent contre les
dockers et leurs proches ses privilèges
accordés par la loi de 47
les dockers bien sûr ne vois pas les
choses ainsi les dockers ne sommes pas
des privilégiés
on peut venir tous les jours sur le port
et ne sont pas responsables de
l'économie
ils ont plongé de revendications
sociales qui à vos porte sur 40% de la
masse salariale
c'est tout et c'est pour cette raison
qu'il se bat mais il ne va pas et ne
voudront pas et se battront comme ils
l'ont toujours fait pour qu'on respecte
leur statut leur loi l'indemnité de
garanties prévues par la loi passera
donc de 84 francs 80 à 96 francs 76 à
partir du 1er août
après cet accord considéré comme
fondamental par les dockers les
conversations devrait reprendre entre
les deux parties afin de s'accorder sur
les points restants sont solutions
c'est-à-dire prise en compte des jours
chômés pour les points de retraite
congés d'ancienneté jours de congés
relèvement des salaires
quant aux revendications propres au port
de fos et portant sur la définition des
nouvelles normes de travail
les négociations sont rompues avec le
patronat
en bref en plein milieu de l'après midi
aujourd'hui à quand un homme d'une
trentaine d'années s'est mis subitement
a tiré plusieurs coups de feu sur des
passants tuant un jeune homme de 17 ans
et blessant quatre autres personnes le
meurtrier a été aussitôt appréhendés par
la police
une erreur dans notre journal d'hier
soir que nous rectifions à propos de
l'intervention des militants du
mouvement greenpeace empêchant un bateau
anglais de rejeter des fûts de déchets
radioactifs en mer l'agencé pour
l'énergie nucléaire de l'oscd une
précise que ces déchets n'ont pas été
immergé dans le golfe de gascogne comme
nous l'avions dit mais à plus de 1000 km
des côtes françaises et sous une
surveillance très stricte tour de france
à la voile l'équipage antenne de barré
par notre envoyé spécial en régaler
continue de suivre les concurrents qui
se trouve ce soir je crois
du côté de deauville temps maussade au
départ de la première étape dunkerque
boulogne pour les 25 équipages du tour
de france à la voile bord à bord les
first 30 s'élancer vers le cap gris nez
le bien nommé pour une course de 80 km
l'arrivée étant jugée à boulogne sur mer
huit heures de navigation au près c'est
à dire face au vent pour les 25 bateaux
avant d'arriver en vue du premier port
de pêche français sur le corps dont le
voilier boulogne-sur-mer le régional de
l'étape en quelque sorte coiffe
marseille
les méridionaux sont des habitués du
tour de france à la voile puisque ce
sont eux qui ont remporté l'épreuve l'an
passé les cinq marseillais défendre à la
fois les couleurs de leur ville et celle
de la marine nationale puis ce qu'ils
effectuent actuellement leur service
militaire dans ce tour de france on ne
trouve pas seulement des bateaux ce
qu'on sait un équipage belge participe à
l'épreuve ottignies louvain la neuve
assainies véhicule m'a séduit
j'avais la possibilité de faire d'autres
gardent cette année mais on s'est
inscrit à celle ci uniquement parce que
c'est la monotypie
très chouette comment ça se passe en mai
un goût d apprendre et par antenne qui
ont continué à lomé problème c'est
montrer le chemin aux autres à
l'apparence les belges que l'on retrouve
au départ de la deuxième étape
boulogne-sur-mer le havre le parcours le
plus long
180 km de course c'est aussi la première
étape de nuit du tour de france à la
voile
ce sont les meilleurs navigateurs qui
l'emporteront sur ce parcours montrant
leur aptitude à naviguer dans les forts
courants que l'on rencontre sur cette
côte marseille creusera très vite
l'écart et après 23 heures de course
emportera avec vingt minutes d'avancé
sur brest
à la décharge des bretons le début d'
incendies dont ils ont été victimes au
cours de la nuit il est parfois
périlleux de cuisine et des pommes de
terre au lard dans l'huisne sous les
rafales de vent une rude étape pour tous
les équipages en particulier pour ceux
qui ont fait passer le sommeil avant la
navigation le voilier d'antenne 2
faisait partie des premiers bien sûr
physiquement c'est dur mais sur le pont
vacation dormir parce qu'on vient
pratiquement
tu t'es demi heure 1
en deux heures on sait pas trop où on va
ça ça dépend des équipes pas chez moi
ils dorment est tout aussi pour faire 30
km le havre deauville aujourd'hui c'est
l'étape la plus courte du tour de france
à la voile le départ a dû être retardée
car l'un des équipiers du voilier quand
tu dois tous les deux jours se présenter
à l'hôpital pour passer quelques heures
sur un officiel au passage saluant son
courage au classement de cette troisième
étape avant le tiercé dont j'ai déjà
l'image est rémois premier le voilier
brest devant la rochelle et boulot une
création général marseille est toujours
en tête le tiercé d'aujourd'hui enghien
pour gagner il fallait jouer le 1 le 4
et le 5 dans l'ordre pour 5 francs 8500
de francs 50 dans le désordre est
toujours conseillé francs 1700 francs 50
centimes je vous en fais cadeau ou la
météo demain le temps sera chaud et
orageux sur la moitié sud de la france
il pleuvra sur les massifs montagneux
sur le reste du pays matinée grise et
brumeuse des éclaircies dans l'après
midi le ciel se couvrira en soirée sur
la manche
on termine en musique avec un reportage
de georges bigot qui a commencé sa
tournée des festivals d'été par celui
d'aix en provence
giuly en passant sera retransmis demain
en direct antenne de midi à partir de
12h30 dernier journal en fin de
programme avec pyrale un bon soir
on
on peut venir à aix faire une cure de
vieilles pierres de soleil de platanes
et de cigales on peut venir ex pour y
prendre les eaux mais depuis le 15
juillet on vient surtout s'y laisser
prendre par la musique
le 32e festival d'aix est ouvert sur les
noces de figaro
comment ne pas être à la fête quand
mozart vous y invite et que la
représentation est éclatante
dans une mise en scène de jorge lavelli
contesté mais que nous trouvons super me
temps par l'intelligence du mouvement
que par la richesse d'invention les
interprètes américains et en particulier
sa nouvelle rame est excellent figaro
ont obtenu un triomphe amplement mérité
au delà du lyrique dans cette ville de
fontaine et de cathédrales la musique
sacrée s'élève naturellement vers la
spiritualité l'orchestré de lille dirigé
par jean claude casadesus a su exalter
les accents et les couleurs contenus
dans l'émouvant requiem de duruflé
si l'on n'obtient pas de place pour le
théâtre de l'archevêché elles sont rares
et chères
le casino d'aix permet de se consoler en
assistant à la projection d'une
rétrospective d'opéra film et on peut
voir fidelio carmen wozzeck ou l'orfeo
de monteverdi par exemple
il n'est pas rare de rencontrer si l'on
se promène un peu un attroupement formé
autour de danseurs car ici en ce mois de
juillet la danse est aussi dans la rue
tous
oui
en
si vous ne venez pas avec cet été ces
textes qui viendra ve
depuis quelques années les concerts et
les spectacles lyriques sont retransmis
par les différentes chaînes de
télévision et france musique antenne 2
vous faudra pour sa part découvrir
porporino une création actuellement en
répétition
bon
dernière dépêche dont je tiens à vous
donner lecture avant de nous quitter
définitivement
on vient d'apprendre que le premier
ministre israëlien monsieur menahem
begin avait été pris d'un malaise cet
après midi au cours d'une réunion du
cabinet israélien qu'il avait été
transporté à l'hôpital de jérusalem je
pense que nous aurons plus de détails
dans le dernier journal que présentera à
pierre-alain en fin de programme bonsoir
excellente soirée sur antenne 2